this is where summer been here every
stone spire here you think I'm inspired
regardless I could be inspired it like I
always inspired if they put me like in a
jail cell I live in an apartment now
it's crazy to me that I don't need a big
house you know you grow up you're like
you know like you don't need a lot of
room with less for me to leave less
stuff I don't need five seventy inch TV
screens I don't need a la I don't I
don't even wear a watch I don't need a
cool watch I don't need to I don't need
a boat like I need the game I know
myself I need the game and that's how I
act other people what you know things
that they don't really mean things that
aren't gonna make them happy they're not
fulfilled inside and so I'm trying
always challenge people to get to their
true self because once you understand
yourself self-awareness is maybe you
should be number two number five number
seven number 12 maybe should be an
accountant not an entrepreneur I mean
you know because you could be one of the
CFO of an entrepreneurs company and make
a billion dollars so they're just that
to me self-awareness is what are you
good at what do you like what puts you
in a position to be successful and so
like then do that
[Music]